the genre of science fiction is vast
there are thousands and thousands of
books to be discovered and enjoyed and
there are also a fair bit of books that
are just uninspired or just downright
bad many of these books are derivative
and shallow and just don't offer
anything new to the genre I recently
completed the first book in the expanse
series Leviathan wakes I was amazed at
by how authors ty Franck and Daniel
Abraham were able to work within the
genre building on some older science
fiction concepts while offering a fresh
new lens through which to view them the
series follows human society in its
early stages of space colonization and I
can say with certainty that the first
book was a great introduction into its
complex and deeply thoughtful narrative
but this video isn't about the expanse
this video is about the novel that is
often cited as the best-selling science
fiction book in history dune dune is a
book for fans who have read a lot of the
genre and are now looking for a
challenge dune is not an easy read by
any stretch of the imagination but the
journey that Frank Herbert takes us on
through his series and the lessons that
we are taught along the way make the
story worthwhile in this video I will do
my best to list some of the top reasons
where the dune saga is actually worth
your time this video will contain
minimal spoilers I assure you
[Music]
the beauty of the writing the beautiful
language that Frank Herbert utilizes
throughout his series is one of the main
things that makes Dunes stand out
Herbert has a way of imbuing his words
with a kind of mysterious power that
makes you want to contemplate single
passages for hours on end
the poetic nature of Frank's writing
makes dune feel operatic and epic giving
the reader a sense of grandiosity it can
be somewhat challenging to decipher the
meaning behind the lyrical language of
dune especially for those that are used
to more straightforward styles of
writing for it Herbert actually
carefully designed the rhythm of dune to
influence the human mind
subconsciously this happens in many
poems the poem then develops a certain
fixed rhythm now by changing the
phraseology the placement of words you
can change that rhythm you can slow it
down you can speed it up well there is
an analogous thing in prose length of
sentence modifying clauses variety of
sentence structure all of these things
control the pace of controlled reading
Frank Herbert believed that even when
language was read silently it was still
received subconsciously as an oral
transmission Frank Herbert wrote doomed
the way he did purposely to control the
oral pacing of the narrative Herbert
described the pacing of dune as a
Collider rhythm starting slowly and
gradually building all the way up and
stopping suddenly at a non-breaking
point Frank Herbert intended the reader
to skid out of the first book trailing
parts of it with them learn the origin
of many science fiction tropes dune was
written in 1965 and has gone on to
influence the entire genre Frank Herbert
famously pointed out that there were 16
points of identity between dune and star
wars Frank Herbert believed that this
was in no way a coincidence at UCLA in
1985 during a talk Frank Herbert
calculated that it was a statistical
impossibility stating the odds of that
being a coincidence there aren't that
many stars in the
George Lucas no doubt borrowed many
elements from the doom saga but the main
themes of both series are actually quite
different there are many other works
that have borrowed elements from dune as
well the extremely expensive substance
the spice melange which had properties
which extended life for those who
ingested it likely inspired Polson
treatments from Dan Simmons Hyperion
cantos and almost certainly inspired the
substance known as booster spice from
Larry Nivens Ringworld series and the
list goes on and on Frank Herbert's
influence even extended out to the
fantasy genre with Robert Jordan likely
modeling the ice ax die on the Binney
jesuits sisterhood if you'd like to hear
more about this specific comparison
check out this video I did not too long
ago dune also inspired the graphic novel
the inkle written by Alejandro
Jodorowsky which itself went on to
inspire the movie The Fifth Element even
Shaun Murray creator of the exploratory
science fiction game no man's sky said
that dune was his favorite book ever and
had a giant influence on who he is as a
person no doubt dooms cultural impact
has been massive expansive imaginative
stories Frank Herbert believed that
stories that were remembered sparks
sparks in the minds of the reader though
a lot of things borrowed from dune there
really is no story quite like the one
portrayed in the dune saga the original
sagas narrative goes on for thousands of
years we see the Empire rise and fall
and rise again we see the culture of the
Imperium as it changes and evolves we
even see how their language evolves over
time Frank Herbert also filled his
universe with many different groups of
human beings each competing like the
Bene Gesserit sisterhood who desired a
specific kind of power they wished to
create the ultimate psychological weapon
or the play lacks ooh the technocratic
xenophobes on the Empire's edge who had
twisted ambitions of their own or the
Exynos the Masters of technological
innovation in the Imperium they
sometimes push the bounds of the ban of
thinking machines
and could very well invent catastrophe
for all the world building or more
accurately put a universe building in
the dune saga is absolutely phenomenal
lessons to be learned there are many
valuable things that one can take from
the dune saga let's look at how Frank
Herbert presents morality and ethics for
instance morality and ethics are two
words that are closely tied but there is
a very distinct difference morality
refers to a person's internal sense of
right and wrong
while ethics stem from a social system
ethics are rules governed by society at
the same time there are collective moral
norms take Furman culture for example
their moral norms are dictated by the
conditions of their environment moral
injunctions grew out of necessity ethics
are formed when a person recognizes the
consequences of moral law and modifies
it for example in the book dune frame
and morals dictate that a new leader
must call out the old one they expect
Paul to do this but Paul recognizes the
usefulness of the old leader and knows
that it would be a loss for them all
here
Paul modifies the frame and moral norm
using ethics and this is just one
example the dune Sava is filled with
these types of philosophical lessons
Frank Herbert's goal was not only to
entertain the reader but to make the
reader think about the meta message
beyond what is presented on the surface
I actually ended up writing a lot more
here about how Frank Herbert presents
the struggle between morality and ethics
but I decided that that needs its own
video there is so much to be said about
dune but obviously most of it can't be
said without spoilers as I have always
maintained dune is not an easy read but
it is a rewarding one if you want to
know more about the dune series click on
the dune playlist in the description of
this video thank you guys so much for
watching make sure you like and
subscribe if you enjoy the video and if
you want to support this channel click
the patreon link in the description also
check me out on Twitter and Facebook